Oh
our lab studies the genome of organisms
and also the genome of cancer cells and
we work on two kinds of problems the
evolution and outcome of cancers and
also on genetic disorders of a
spontaneous sort that is non heritable
genetic disorders and those are two very
sounds like two very different things
but they're they're related by our
methodology which is genomic analysis
what we do is we would call difference
analysis for example if we're looking at
a cancer will want to see where that
cancer has mutated relative to the
genome of the person who gave rise to
that cancer that's differential genomic
analysis and it tells us where the
cancer is mutated and from the types of
mutations the number of mutations we can
infer a lot about cancer ideology
well biology has always been influenced
strongly by quantitative types many
physicists in the late thirties early
forties fifties came into biology
strongly influenced it there was a
period I would say from the time I was a
graduate student in the mid-70s till the
mid to late 90s where it was not
particularly quantitative and that was
largely because of the revolution in
recombinant DNA so really all you needed
to be to be a good biologist was a good
sense of logic and a good imagination
and mathematical and statistical skills
are weren't really that necessary for
much of biology and I was in that group
actually I'd studied earlier on as a
mathematician but I did used almost none
of those of the mathematical tools when
doing biological research of course the
logic comes in handy but the tools were
not very valuable there's no place for
them because the kind of data that we
were getting was very individual data
and I actually had a rule of thumb rule
of thumb i actually disliked statistics
early on in my in my life and i felt
that if if i needed to do statistics to
see what I was observing that I wasn't
really observing anything but that
changed with the advent of the
sequencing of the human genome that
changed everything and the development
of new high-throughput methods of
extracting data if forced biologists
reconsider the value of statistics and
mathematics in the analysis of their
subject so a number of biologists moved
in that direction not a lot but quite a
number did and I was one of those that
moved in that direction
you know we are so close historically to
that period and the data that's coming
out of that effort is still being
generated I think it's very hard for any
of us to really judge the impact that it
has had it was a huge revolution in
terms of the kinds of experiments one
who conceived of doing the only thing
comparable in my lifetime was the
recombinant DNA revolution which changed
entirely the kinds of experiments that
people did since sequencing methods are
changing so fast i mean the the cost of
sequencing is is has dropped enormously
and with each drop in the cost it
changes entirely how you how do you
think of attacking a problem so in a few
years from now we'll be in a position to
have DNA sequence of very high quality
for a million people and know the
medical history of these million people
and there will be you know I don't even
think our computers are yet to a stage
where they'll be able to handle data
that type and the kind of analysis tools
that will be needed to analyze that
haven't been developed yet so we're in a
really estranged point in the history of
biology where things are changing so
rapidly we don't really we really can't
quite see the shape of the future yet